so you mentioned the gossip as one of
the people in your story at Kirchhoff
Institute can you tell the story and
your involvement in Chernobyl sort of
that played a part in our lives as well
so what's the story there
Wood is Chernobyl okay for people who
don't know yeah Chernobyl it's a it's a
small city town with a huge nuclear
power plant and it's the place of world
ever biggest nuclear severe accident the
reason of this accident the best if you
know fix but other people they can watch
the movie which is the HBO show
yeah show very good actually I did not
expect but it is really very good the
major reason is they just went through
special tests and just testing new
regimes and they start to decrease
activity of reactor very fast and the
reactor starts dying and they just
increase activity and then they were
unable to stop it and the temperature go
very high metal clothing start reacting
with cooling water producing hydrogen
hydrogen reacts with oxygen and it was a
huge hydrogen explosion the so-called
DDT and because of this explosion
actually they're very very very very
heavy like a tip of the reactor jump up
blow down and fully tongs or something
like that I froze huge just and destroy
the whole reactor and all this nuclear
fuel start falling down create some
critical mass
and it was a nuclear explosion but not
contained so yes it was what part of the
story did the show get right and what
part of story did you get wrong any of
you the gossip just things you've
experienced yeah personal no I just
very shortly described what happened yes
that like it was this kind of already
nuclear expansion and everything from
inside was boom went out and actually
with the wind make almost a half circle
around the world
so that's accident for instead of atomic
energy it was a very big deal because
the whole community the whole country
actually they consider that this huge
Institute is responsible for this
accident so the reaction don't forget
it's a communist country they decided
it's like like an army that all people
all scientists they are responsible dust
matter whatever if you doing plasma or
you're doing nuclear reactor does matter
you have to go and help you want it you
don't want it you like it you don't like
it in the movie it was shown but I would
say movie is about 97 percent absolutely
great so weaker
it's unbelievable how good they made
this nice they made this movie there
from the people the culture the science
everything lady direction the
bureaucracy yeah yeah yeah yeah
they did not overdo that because it's
very easy to goal against the eyes the
communist country that's why and vice
versa so they did it very good harmony
very good balance yeah that was perfect
were they get wrong here at least my
impression is that they show the
apartment of Lagasse's the gossip was
actually almost a copy of real [ __ ]
visually - yes yes yes yes as this actor
he looks like legal and just you know
Wow just like as a good actor actually
it's a good actor British you know and
that's but it was shown that's like a
little bit of already American
propaganda they show this the gas of
living in like a small apartment like a
smoking cigarettes all right no come on
it was can you imagine like a vice
president of Academy of Sciences vice
president of creative initiative he
lives an apartment come especially in
the Soviet Union where that position
means you get you get handed given out
the apartment he lead no not an
apartment it was like a special house
belonging to him it is like a next door
to the Institute it this house did not
belong to him yeah but that's where he
lived so just he lived like in a in a
castle and like a movie it was what's
your memory of him have you I know your
madam come on he's my supervisor so like
okay so it's like have you it's like it
like Moshe for you yeah like I had like
a rusinov
and like for you it was severe and like
the Gaza for me is like a motor camp so
did have chance to see Moshe come here
is he all laughing it's like each other
day every day um
my feeling is he was very good in
nuclear chemistry he was a he was a
member and very significant member of
Communist Party the difference was
Roseanna Roseanna was not very much
liking communists very well the gossip
he was so he was a secretary of
communist party organization of Kolkata
he did for a couple of years so this
kind of personality so he was a great
scientist very interesting very bright
but at the same time he was a communist
and he kind of believed in this
communist ideas and he took all that
responsibility very close to his heart
and that's exactly like it is shown in
the movie especially when the director
of the Chernobyl station made a
incredibly strange mistake because the
record was already destroyed
you remember my explanation but what
they see the temperature is going up and
his decision was you know your inertial
intelligence not so much in physics and
chemistry but if temperature is going up
what people they do if they are not
professionals let's put water there and
he made the decision to put an enormous
amount of water into the rector to cool
it down but people they took him come on
I just we have seen a couple of seconds
ago there is no reactor there is nothing
to cool down because it's now can we
mention this huge temperature and you
put water into this huge temperature and
metals metals immediately react with
water producing hydrogen
so actually what they did it's it's it's
it's extremely bad and it's nicely shown
in the movie they made the decision for
three people to go inside under director
and open the valve to let this hot water
to let this water out and these people
they did it obviously it was clear that
they were going to die do you think the
accident could have been avoided the
Chernobyl accident you know it's so
deeply interlinked just Soviet culture
say no I know you know how to say is it
possible to be sure that it will be no
fire in the city um it is it's very low
probability it's a sexual innocence it's
a couple of stuff with extremely low
probability happened at the same time
but it was really important stuff
Chernobyl happened first of all because
it was no automatic system of control it
was impossible if they say already
accident there is no automatic system to
stop it oh why because it's a huge
reactor very heavy very very very heavy
in big way bigger than reactors which we
have here in the United States so this
is very more difficult to control so I
would say it was clear for many people
that sooner or later it will be this
accident and actually it is a copy of
accident which happened in America in
try my island it's very similar but
American accident was more
better controlled so it was not so huge
years to see their excellent
well legassik he took the stuff very
close to his heart and and it is very
nicely shown in the movie and actually
that's why he suicide he took his own
life
yeah yeah and by the way he tried twice
first time not successful a second one
so there's a there's a journey of
suffering there afterwards he he he took
you know he were the burden of credit
for that the responsibility and yes
because actually he was claiming that
these reactors are the safest in the
world
yeah and they are but the they're way
more resistive to small accidents right
and yet they have this tiny chance of
severe accident even now a lot of these
reactors are still the same are still
the same and still around
you